[Music]  this is the collared lizard  the two black bands around their neck  give them their name  coloured lizards can actually run on  their hind legs and reach up to 15 miles  per hour  their tails are used for balancing  themselves when they are up and  sprinting  they are a medium-sized lizard reaching  up to a foot and a half in length  native to western north america they  prefer to live in rocky habitats with  sparse vegetation  today they are widespread but only a few  decades ago their population was  declining clearing land as a form of  fire prevention has greatly helped its  population rebound  as they need open rocky habitats to  survive  this is the colored lizard  [Music]  you